astronomy keeps advancing and people in
our modern age find out something new
about space practically on a monthly
basis as a rule scientists concern
themselves with objects located billions
of kilometers away from our earth
however there are a lot of exciting
things comparatively near the solar
system
i've already told you about the
boundaries of the observable universe
about what there is to be found beyond
our galaxy and about the nearest
exoplanet proxima centauri b
now it's time to take a peep at a
celestial object equally worthy of our
attention namely the brightest star in
our sky sirius
most people perceive it as one single
star
however in reality sirius is a binary
stellar system consisting of two space
objects sirius a and series b
both stars orbit around their common
gravity center at a distance of
approximately 20 astronomical units
just to compare this is only one
astronomical unit more than the distance
from uranus to the sun
their orbital period around the gravity
center is 50 years
serious a is the main component
it is a visible star of spectral type a1
which has long been perceived as the
only star in the system
it is about two sun masses with the
radius exceeding that of the sun by 71
percent
due to its close proximity series a is
one of the easiest objects for amateur
astronomers
the sky is 8.6 light years away from our
system
and its brightness is 25 times as
intense as that of the sun in addition
to its superiority over our main star in
terms of its dimensions and mass this
celestial object also beats it in the
temperature level which may reach
9940 kelvins on its surface as opposed
to only
5778 kelvins on the sun
the most exciting peculiarity of the
object is a high level of iron in its
atmosphere
which is 316 percent as abundant as on
the sun
also the spectrum shows that other
elements heavier than helium are to be
found
the star is likely to have been enriched
in metallic elements tens of millions of
years ago by a neighboring object
speaking about its future evolution
serious a will probably continue to
exist as it is for another 600 million
years or so
after which it will turn into a red
giant
and then a white dwarf
even though only several thousand white
dwarfs are known to science today
this kind of final state is typical of
stars relatively similar to our sun in
terms of dimensions and mass
these objects are hard to discover which
has to do with their low luminosity and
small diameter
however according to scientists their
overall number in our galaxy is
estimated to reach 10 billion that is
about five percent of all stars in the
milky way
the second component of the serious
stellar system is exactly one of such
objects which is the first white dwarf
to have been discovered
as far back as in 1844 the famous german
astronomer friedrich bessel noticed that
the trajectory of serious a from time to
time deviates from its linear motion
bezel accounted for this behavior by
suggesting the existence of a hidden
mass orbiting together with a star
around a common center
this hypothesis caused a lot of
skepticism for if it held good the mass
of the latent satellite was supposed to
equal that of our sun
nevertheless 18 years later in january
vessel's assumptions proved to be true
while testing a new 46 centimeter
refractor
the american astronomer alvin graham
clark cited a tiny star near sirius
orbital movement corresponded to
friedrich bessel's calculations
the star was dubbed serious b
this object is the heaviest white dwarf
of all known to science
and has approximately the mass of the
sun
but even in spite of this indicator not
typical of this celestial object's
variety its volume accounts for less
than one millionth of that of the sun
and its dimensions are mystique while
those of the earth
before becoming a white dwarf the star
is likely to have completed the two
basic stages of star evolution
the main sequence stage and then the red
giant stage
scientists believe that the process of
turning into a white dwarf took place
approximately 120 million years ago and
the star's mass used to be five times
that of the sun
at this moment
sirius b is barely luminous
with its luminosity being 0.026 that of
the sun
and with an exceptionally high
temperature of 25 200 kelvins on its
surface
as sirius b has no internal heat source
it will gradually cool off and will
eventually become a hypothetical black
dwarf in over 2 billion years time
however this kind of objects hasn't been
cited by scientists yet
unlike its younger neighbor this star
isn't easily observable in our sky
which is the reason why sirius b has
long been inadvertently ignored by
science
only on october the 15th 2003 did
scientists receive a clearer image of
the object with the help of the hubble
telescope
both stars are visible in this picture
sirius a the brighter one and sirius b
the tiny one
the object is located in the well-known
constellation canis major in the
southern hemisphere of the sky
but it is visible to the naked eye in
the northern hemisphere as well
due to its perfect visibility sirius has
been studied by mankind for a great
number of years getting shrouded by an
increasing number of legends as far back
as an ancient egypt the object was
referred to as the nile star and was
associated with the name of the goddess
subdead as its morning rise heralded the
river flooding during the summer
solstice sirius is mentioned in the
works of the roman scientists sunica and
ptolemy who described the star as
scarlet the object also holds a place in
the history of mesopotamian and chinese
astronomy it is also characteristically
referred to as a bright red star
due to such conflicting descriptions
sirius became notorious for being the
object of manifold pseudoscientific
theories
the temporary reddening of the star can
be explained by the influence of
interstellar dust which for a while came
between sirius and the earth with the
effect of giving the radiance a reddish
hue
another explanation could line the
possibility of there being a third
component in the system
whose orbital period equals about 2 000
years
when in close proximity to sirius a
this hypothetical celestial object could
cause the star to flush red
nonetheless to date nothing even faintly
resembling this kind of object has been
discovered
in april 2018 nasa launched the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite
tess with the aim of finding exoplanets
orbiting bright stars
due to the fact that sirius is a young
star it is rather unlikely that any
planets will be discovered in its
environs
but the satellite will collect data that
will facilitate its investigation in
more detail
even if there is at least one big planet
in this system
life cannot be sustained there as too
little time has passed since the
formation of the star itself
apart from that any planets within the
habitable zone must have been burned out
when serious beer was in its red dwarf
stage and as a result there is as good
as no chance of discovering any life
forms in this system
sirius is likely to be a relatively
young system according to modern
estimates as well its age gauged as
being between 200 to 300 million years
procyon is the closest star to sirius
being 5.2 light years away
the sun holds the sixth place on this
list
although this may well change in the
future
the point is that sirius approaches our
system at the speed of 7.6 kilometers
per second which is why its brightness
visible to us is going to gradually
intensify
sirius will remain the brightest star in
our sky for thousands of years to come
after which the process is supposed to
be reversed with the star growing ever
dimmer to the observer on our earth
in our modern age some may think
astronomy to be a young science as most
discoveries are being made with the use
of state-of-the-art equipment
however the movements of celestial
bodies have been studied throughout the
entire history of mankind
and the star sirius is a perfect
confirmation of this
we respect our audience that is you dear
subscribers that is why we cherry-pick
the most cutting-edge items from the
world of science
your support by liking our videos
motivates us to move on and set
ourselves yet another challenge
i would also like to thank all those
sponsoring us on the patreon platform
it is thanks to you that our project
keeps going i hope you've enjoyed the
video so we'll try to treat you to a few
more exciting ones in just a bit
let's keep in touch